[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to the
Data Science Hangout.
It's so nice to see
everybody today.
If this is your first
time joining us today--
I know there was a lot of
love for Matt on LinkedIn,
so we might have
some people here
joining for the very first time.
Thank you for joining us.
This is an open space for the
whole data science community
to connect and chat about data
science leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting to
learn about what's going on
in the world of data science
across different industries
and companies.
So the sessions are
recorded, and they're
shared to the Posit on YouTube,
as well as our Data Science
Hangout site.
So you can always go
back and rewatch or find
helpful resources.
Together at the Data
Science Hangouts,
we're dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment
for everybody, so we love
when you all can participate
and we can hear from everyone,
no matter your area of work
or level of experience too.
There's always multiple ways
you can ask questions-- and not
just ask questions, but also
provide your perspective.
So if there's something you
want to jump in and weigh in on,
you can jump in by raising
your hand on Zoom here.
You can put questions or
comments into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it
if you want me to read it too.
I see a lot happening
in the chat right now.
But I could also call on you
to introduce yourselves and add
some context too.
We also have a Slido link
where you can ask questions
anonymously, and our
team will put that
into the chat in
just a second here.
But with all of that,
thanks again for joining.
I'm so excited to be joined by
my co-host today, Matt Dancho,
founder of Business Science.
And we were just talking.
Matt and I spoke at
the RStudio Conference
back in July about the hangouts.
We were like, let's get
something on the books,
and here we finally are.
So thanks for joining, Matt.
I'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share
a little bit about--
MATT DANCHO: Sure.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: --the
work you do and--
Yeah, yeah.
Well, first off, Rachael,
thanks so much for having me.
We were chatting
and we had talked
about doing this back in July,
which was when the RStudio
Conference was going on.
And like you said, things
have just flown by,
and here we are in November.
And this is exciting.
I'm excited to be here, so
thank you so much for having me.
Just to introduce
myself, my name's Matt.
If you guys haven't ever met me
before, it's great to meet you.
Thanks so much for showing up.
I don't know what
your background is.
It sounds like there might
be beginners, experts,
maybe a mix here.
So do me a favor.
If you're a beginner, can you
put just a three in the chat?
Just put the number
three so I can
get a sense of where we're at.
All right, all right, all right.
OK.
And if you're an expert,
put a five in the chat.
Robert, five.
MATT DANCHO: All right, 4
and 1/2, 4 and 1/2, yeah.
[LAUGHING] All right, cool, so
we've got a good mix of people.
So I like to ask this
just so I know how to--
before I start diving into
what I do and everything,
just to get a general
consensus on--
wow, we got a negative five--
just to see where you
guys are at skill-wise.
And the cool thing is, no
matter where you're coming from,
you're going to learn stuff.
We're here.
We're open.
Like Rachael said, we're open,
so feel free to ask questions.
Little bit about myself--
my name is Matt Dancho.
I've been doing R for about--
I want to say 2013 was like
officially my moment when I--
yeah, I'm going for
into this thing--
which, back then it was
just statistics or--
it wasn't even I don't think
quite called data science.
You guys probably can
identify with this.
I got bit by the R bug bad.
I became obsessed,
and I just started
like learning as much
as I possibly could
and trying to apply
it to my day job
at the time, which I was
working for a small company
called Bonney Forge.
And I was just helping them
handle their customer data,
work with the
manufacturing team,
understand-- back then
there was a big drop in oil
prices and the
products that we made
went into oil, so I was doing
a lot of forecasting and things
of that nature.
So fast forward to today,
in 2018, I got into--
2017, 2018, I got into
consulting kind of as a side
hustle at first, and then it
slowly became my full-time job.
And then in 2018, I
pivoted into education,
because that's where I really
saw a huge demand for--
as I was doing a lot
of these consulting
projects for companies in the
marketing domain or finance
domain, it was clear to me that
the problem wasn't that they
needed a consultant.
They really needed education
and they needed help.
So in 2018 I founded
Business Science.
So that's my company.
And since then, I've been
building a lot of courses.
That's what the first
four years were.
And now we're
getting to the point
where we're starting to
add additional programs
and scale up the programs too.
So now we have about, I think,
4,000 or 5,000 students,
and in 2018, we
started with one.
So it's been kind
of a wild ride.
Are any of you guys students--
Business Science students
on the call today?
Put a one in the chat.
Javier, yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Oh, I see some.
That's awesome.
MATT DANCHO: All right, sweet.
Sweet.
So what was really cool
back in RStudio Conference--
I got to meet a
ton of my students.
I met, I think, over 30 students
of mine, and it's really cool.
I got pictures with them,
got to talk with them,
got to see them face to face.
And I had no clue,
I didn't even think
I was going to run
into a single student.
For me it's a humbling moment,
because I see business science
education is getting out there
and it's having an impact,
and those are the cool
things that I like to see.
All right.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Absolutely.
Yeah.
MATT DANCHO: I probably went
a little deeper than what
you may have wanted, but--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Sorry.
We had a little--
here, I'm going
to ask RStudio co-host to help
with the mute buttons here.
Let's see.
There we go.
Thanks, everybody.
I do see some questions
already coming in, Matt.
And this is one
that I actually was
really interested
to ask you about as
well, your journey
going from your company
to starting your own business.
And the question says,
Matt, I'm really eager.
Could you take us
through your journey
to becoming a mini
celeb in the space?
MATT DANCHO: Oh my gosh.
Was it scary to go off
and do your own thing?
MATT DANCHO: It was.
So I'll talk a little bit
about what was going on.
So the tough part for me
was giving up a six-figure--
a cushy six-figure job,
salary to do something new
and take on a risk.
And I think, as an
entrepreneur, it's something
that I've always wanted to
do, but you never really know
when the timing is right.
In 2017, I had started slowly--
I made the decision to
build my first course,
and I didn't know what
it was going to do.
I launched it in 2018.
I think it was April or May of
2018, and I got 50 people in it
really quick.
That to me was a huge
signal that there
was an actual demand.
Was it enough to
offset my salary
and feel like, oh, yeah,
I'm going to do it?
No, not at all.
So some things happened
later throughout that year.
I want to say maybe middle of
2018, so like August of 2018,
I ended up making the
decision to leave my company,
and again, give
up that cushy job.
It was a huge risk
at that point.
And I remember even
throughout that year--
I remember in
December of that year,
I think I only made like
$3,000 or $4,000 that month.
And this is coming
from somebody who
was making a lot,
probably three or four
times that amount every month.
And there was definitely
some question marks,
like am I going to be
able to pull this off?
But for me, the
things that really
help when I decided to
actually take that step forward
was sitting down,
looking at the numbers,
figuring out what people
want, talking to customers,
talking to my
students at that time,
figuring out what their
needs were, and then really
just giving it my all.
I looked at the numbers
and I saw that, hey,
if we could do this
amount each month,
we're going to be
able to be fine.
My wife, she was still working
full time at that point.
That for me was like, OK--
January of 2019,
I put my head down
and just started working
and building courses, and--
after reviewing the numbers,
and got the confidence in myself
to really be able to do it.
And I just started doing it.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: That's great.
And something that we've
talked about a few times
on past weeks of the
hangout is on building
your personal brand, and I
think that's something that you
do a really great job of.
I know we originally met
on LinkedIn, I think.
MATT DANCHO: Yep.
And I was just
curious, for people
who are jumping into this
space too and looking
to build their personal brand,
do you have any tips for us?
MATT DANCHO: Yeah, absolutely.
So Rachael, building
your personal brand--
and you know this, because
you've done a fantastic
job as well,
especially with being
part of RStudio and Pause--
I think you're doing
a fantastic job--
--at this.
But everyone can really benefit
from building a personal brand.
It doesn't matter
if you're trying
to get a job, if you're trying
to build your own company,
if you're trying to do--
even just grow yourself
personally and step out
of your comfort zone.
I think it's really
important for everyone
to build their own brand.
Some tips I can give you--
don't feel like you
need to get it perfect.
There's a guy that
I follow on Twitter.
His name is Justin Welsh.
And he does a
really good job at--
for people who are trying to
start their own business, how
to do your own personal brand.
Some of the value that
I've gotten from him--
talking about your journey.
No matter where you
are, just every day,
just going on
LinkedIn, or maybe--
make it a point two
or three times a week.
Just put a post out
there of something
new that you've learned or
something you're interested in.
And it doesn't have to be a
whole production, because this
is the mistake
that I always made
was I always felt like my
copy has to be super on point
and it needs to be something
I've thought about for days.
And while that
stuff does work, I
think what is more
valuable is being authentic
and just kind of showing
like, hey, I'm not perfect.
I learned something.
I'm excited about it.
I've learned this new R package.
People identify with
that, and then you
start to grow your followers.
And that can lead to
new job opportunities.
That can lead to never know who
that connection's going to be.
And they may be the person
that helps you, because we all
need help, right?
No matter where you are,
you're not going to get--
you're not going to be the
best version of yourself
without getting a little
bit of help along the way.
And I think using LinkedIn
and using Twitter to that,
and just posting a little bit
about your journey every--
doesn't have to be every day--
of times each week really--
that'll make a huge difference.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
That's really helpful.
I'm starting to see
some questions coming in
through the chat too.
So Jeremy, I see you
just asked a question.
Do you want to jump
in live and ask it?
I see you unmuted, but I'm
not sure I can hear you yet.
Yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Oh, there you are.
Hey.
I'm just interested.
I do some online teaching, and
I do a lot of meetings online.
I'm still working from home.
So I'm just interested
in how you--
what technology you use to
get the best experience when
you're connecting
with people remotely--
hardware and software.
And how do you integrate
R into these technologies?
MATT DANCHO: OK, OK.
Great question, Jeremy.
The main types of
softwares that I use--
I mean, Zoom--
I do a webinar once every--
I was doing it every two weeks.
Now I'm going to
do it every week.
But I usually try
to do a webinar,
and I try to teach a little
bit about R and certain topics.
One that I'm actually getting
ready to teach is time series.
I'm going to be
doing that next week.
But every week or
every couple of weeks,
I try to get on a
Zoom webinar with--
I just open it up to
everybody, because it's
kind of a way to give back.
It's something that I'm very
interested in helping people
grow their R experience, because
I think too, oftentimes, you
see people out there and
they just don't know about R,
or they may be on the edge
of, should I do data science?
Could I do data science?
I'm working in Excel right now.
I'm doing Power BI, but
what else can I do--
be doing to grow my career?
So doing a webinar--
so Zoom for webinars
is fantastic.
Trying to think what else.
Obviously, I use the RStudio
product line, or the Posit
product line, but RStudio--
the IDE is fantastic.
Shiny-- I think that is such
a misunderstood technology
out there that people
kind of often overlook.
So I love showcasing
Shiny as a way
to really take R into
production, because everyone
always talks about MLOps and
putting things into production.
How do you do that with R?
Guys, it's right there.
It's Shiny.
It's fantastic.
And let's see.
What else?
What other
technologies do I use?
I mean, through my
business, I probably
touch 30 or 40
different technologies.
And we could probably
talk all day about those.
But do you have anything
specific, Jeremy,
that you're interested in?
JEREMY SKOG: No, I'm just
interested in hearing about how
you keep people engaged who've
been in meetings all day
and then tune in to
another Zoom meet-up.
Yeah.
OK, this is good,
because something
I started working
with is actually
a coach and an a
marketing guy as well.
And that's really helped me
in my presentation skills,
because in the online
age, it's really tough
to capture people's engagement.
So I don't know how
deep, Rachael, you
want to go into the
art of presentations.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Let's
dive in, whatever--
--everybody wants
to task about.
MATT DANCHO: All right.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yeah.
If you guys want
to go, I'll go.
All right.
When you do a
presentation, people
are on Zoom calls all day.
With COVID and everything,
the last thing you want to do
is you want to just
get on to a Zoom call
and just talk at
people for 60 minutes.
And that's the last thing
that they want to do too,
because they're going to be--
after the first three minutes,
they're going to tune you out,
right?
So what we started doing
on our marketing webinars
and on our technical webinars
is really just trying
to keep the engagement up.
So what I did here with like
the threes and the fives,
that's a way to engage.
So you just ask a
question to the audience,
and oftentimes, that keeps
them kind of in there
that much longer.
I have a note on my keyboard--
don't be boring.
And so I will do weird stuff.
I've started to play around
with the way that I talk.
So I used to talk just like
I would conversationally,
but in a webinar you want to
talk a little bit differently.
You want to actually accentuate
your speech patterns.
So if you have kind
of a long sentence--
I'm talking about
RStudio, how great it is,
and I want to make
sure that you get
the most important
information today,
and these are the three things
I want you to walk away with.
So I'll play around with
my speech a little bit.
Those inflection points
will keep people interested.
And also, starting everything
with a big promise,
like, hey, why are
you here today?
What are you going
to get out of it?
So I started doing
this big promise
at the beginning of my webinars.
And I just started
saying, hey, I'm
going to teach you
one thing today.
If you don't walk away from
this presentation with anything
else, this is what
you're going to do today.
And for my time series
presentation or for--
I just did one on
techs analysis.
It was one skill
that they're going
to learn that is really going
to allow them to improve
their model performance
and potentially
save their company up
to a million dollars.
So it's something big that
they're going to walk away,
and they're going to see at
the end how we accomplish that.
I think you do a
couple of those things,
and you're going to see that
your Zoom calls, your webinars
that you're on-- especially
if you're training
data scientists,
some of that stuff
can get dull pretty quickly.
I often think that
the more that they can
identify with you as a person--
so I'll mix in a
little bit of my story,
usually in the
beginning of my talks.
Especially for new people that
aren't accustomed to you yet,
I think that that
makes a big difference.
So that was a good question.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Yeah, great question.
JEREMY SKOG: That's great.
Thank you.
That's really helpful, Matt.
I've been thinking a lot
about a lot of the communities
that people build within
their own companies too,
and getting people engaged
and interested in those.
That's really helpful
snippet for us.
MATT DANCHO: Yeah.
And I think case studies too--
people often in companies--
what I saw was,
even though you're
on the same team,
a lot of times you
don't see what they're doing.
So sharing just a case
study or an example of how
you're using R in that
company can oftentimes
help grow R within--
inside the walls, because
you might be in the marketing
group, but the
manufacturing group
may have a similar situation
that they don't even
know that it can help them.
So yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Absolutely.
MATT DANCHO: Share.
Tell stories.
Talk about your case studies.
All that's really good stuff.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Marlene, I see you
asked a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Hey, Matt.
Good morning or afternoon.
I don't know what time
zone people are in.
I'm in Key West right now,
so I'm East Coast time zone.
It is just noon-- just hit noon.
MARLENE HANKEN: OK.
MATT DANCHO: Nice
to see you, Marlene.
We just had the time shift,
so I'm super discombobulated.
People on the call
were [INAUDIBLE] me.
My question was around starting
to socialize data sharing,
and it's a struggle for
certain organizations.
And I'm just wondering if
you've handled that a bit
as a consultant.
Obviously, you deal a lot with
the real hands-on data work,
but how do you start to
address, or like I said,
socialize the concept of
breaking down some silos
and barriers to data sharing?
I don't know if you
can just go, hey,
it's as easy as RStudio Connect
or whatever you recommend, or--
I don't how.
How do you start having
that conversation?
So I'm a big fan of
including as many stakeholders
throughout the
project as possible.
So a typical example might be,
if I was doing a consulting
project with one of the
companies I work with back
in the day, like S&amp;P
Global, MRM//McCann.
They're a big marketing firm.
S&amp;P Global, they're
in the finance.
So I normally have
a point of contact
there that I'm working with.
But what I'll try and do is,
as we come up with the project
discovery phase, I'll ask
a lot of questions like,
what are your pain points?
How does this affect
your organization?
Really try to go a couple
layers deep with them.
And what ends up happening
is they'll be like, oh, yeah,
well, this affects this
part of the company.
It's like, well,
should we involve them
in the conversation?
And they're like, yeah, it's
probably not a bad idea.
So you start building
a group of people.
And then once you get
them all filled in
on what you guys
are trying to do,
that often just helps
break down the silos,
and they can understand
and talk in an open forum
where everyone's equal, and just
really try to understand this--
whatever that problem is,
because most of the time,
the data science team--
you're kind of acting
like a consultant.
A lot of times,
my impression of--
is they're almost doing
a consulting capacity
inside of an organization.
So the toughest part is
to be able to get everyone
comfortable so that, number one,
they give you access to data.
But number two, get--
just get them talking
and communicating
so that way you really
can break down those--
I don't know if they're
silos or barriers-- whatever
you want to call it.
But you've got to break this
down so everyone's talking,
and then that's going to make
them more comfortable for sure.
MARLENE HANKEN: Got it.
Yeah, I appreciate that.
It's a struggle, and
you hit the nail right
on the head in operating on
kind of like a consultancy.
That's what I feel like.
I am running around to about--
we're a family of
companies, six companies.
So I'm calling each of the
companies saying, what's
top of the priority list?
What are you trying to
automate and/or work towards?
I'm on a five- or
six-year plan to get us
into machine learning, so it's
going to be a long haul still.
But I appreciate it.
What company do you work with,
if you don't mind me asking?
Sure.
I work for Western Growers.
We're a trade association for
specialty crops growers, so not
corn and not
[INAUDIBLE] of those.
So basically, if you enjoy leafy
greens, anybody on the call,
we take care of the growers
that leafy greens all
over the country.
90% of your leafy
greens in California.
Yeah.
Thank you for [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHS]
MATT DANCHO: Yeah, I mean, it's
not going to happen overnight,
so I'm glad you guys
have an actual plan
that you guys are working to--
although you might be surprised.
You can get it done probably
faster than five years,
depending on how large your
organization is and how much
of that what-- do they call it--
corporate inertia, so to speak.
But yeah, and the technology
will play a big role too.
So you mentioned
RStudio Connect.
I think that's a
fantastic product.
I think just
getting quick wins--
anytime you can get
something simple, quick,
out there, that is going to be--
that's going to gain
their confidence in you
and your ability to
manage that project.
And I think that
that's going to help
you grow your net, the net
that you're trying to cast.
So that's what I recommend.
Yeah, go for quick wins.
Get them all in meetings.
Communicate.
Make sure you go a couple
levels deep with them.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
I don't want to
dominate the call,
because there are a
lot of other questions,
but there's a lot
going on here that--
I'm just throwing tons
of irons in the fire
and trying to build
some traction here,
and definitely going
crazy planning.
So thanks so much, Matt.
I appreciate it.
Yep, You got it.
You got it.
No problem.
I'm seeing lots of
love for both Shiny
and leafy greens in
the chat right now.
[LAUGHTER]
Alan, I see you
asked a question.
You want to jump in?
Sure.
Yeah.
Hi, Matt.
I'm really, really
curious about the identity
of the company, as you
call it, Business Science,
and wanted to get you to maybe
speak to that a little bit
more.
I read it as being intentionally
specific about the embeddedness
of data work in organizations
and towards focused business
problem solving,
and a little bit
different from a lot of
the positioning of data
science learning as
hard core data science.
And I wonder if that's true.
And if so, how do you--
what does that mean for the
way you design your courses,
for the way you pitch what
the company does for people
and that sort of thing?
How is that a day-to-day part
of the identity of the company?
MATT DANCHO: Right.
That's a good question,
Alan, and I'm really
glad you brought that up.
So the identity of my
company Business Science
has actually evolved over time.
Initially, I was just trying
to combine business and data
science in a way,
and I'm a very--
I want to be-- it to be
obvious what the naming
of the company--
I'm not like a
company like Apple,
where I'm going to
call myself Apple
and then it's going to be
a technology company that
builds phones, and computers,
and those sorts of things,
and all the other
stuff that they do now.
That's originally why I
called it Business Science.
And again, my roots
were in consulting,
so I was actually applying
data science to business,
and that's really--
was the crux of what I
was trying to go after.
And when I was coming up
with the training initially,
that's really what I
wanted to emphasize
is a business-forward or a
business-first type of way
of learning data science.
Now, with that said,
things have changed
a lot in the past four
years, or five years
that I've been
running this thing.
And I will say this.
Seriously, I actually view--
and we can get at a really
deep level of conversation
on this, but I really view
that data scientists and data
analysts--
I think that there's going
to be a new roll here
in the next couple of years
that companies are going
to start adopting the role
of the business scientist,
because you already
have a business analyst.
And I haven't really talked
a whole lot about this yet,
but the more I think about it,
the problem and the challenge
with data science and
why companies often
fail with data science,
it's not because they have--
they don't have
good people or they
don't have problem
solvers or this or that,
but they lose sight of the
business-first mentality, where
you need to be able to
start with a problem
in an organization,
be able to work
with many different levels
of the organization,
from executives
to line managers,
the people who are
doing the work.
And you have to work
cross-functionally
and cross-sectional
throughout the company.
And that to me requires a heavy
business acumen, not just like,
hey, I know data, and
I know a few algorithms
that I can throw at the data.
No, that's not how it goes.
The most successful
people that I've seen
are the ones that are able
to communicate effectively,
that know what the target
is of the organization,
the objectives, and they can
translate that into all the
different--
they can take that
down and translate it
across the organization.
The more and more that
I think about this,
I really view that there is--
probably in the next couple
of years, you're going to
start seeing actual roles on--
within companies on Indeed
for the business scientists.
And I'm going to start
promoting that here actually--
start in 2023 you'll see more
of me talking about that.
So good question.
ALAN SCHUSSMAN: That's great.
Thanks.
I love hearing the
evolution and your--
the way that what you're
seeing in the industry
and in companies is informing
how your thinking moves,
and really, really
resonates, everything
you're saying about
being tightly connected,
about the work matters
because it's solving problems
that people need us to solve.
Yeah, really, really cool.
Thanks.
MATT DANCHO: Awesome.
Well, thanks a lot for
that question, Alan.
Oh, my daughter is--
I'm really excited to see--
oh.
[CHUCKLES]
That was my daughter Shea.
She's a-- [CHUCKLES]
just came in to say hi.
Here, I'm going to shut
the door real quick.
No worries.
Hey, Rachael.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Hey.
Yes.
I was going to say, jump
in there [INAUDIBLE]..
I see your hand raised.
Yeah, So it's funny.
Eugene just made
a comment that's
along the same lines
of where I'm thinking.
So my team at Peloton
just got a new VP,
and one of the very
first things that he
began talking about is product
management within our team,
which is kind of shifting
us away from this project
management-based style of
intake and prioritization
to strictly aligning
ourselves with stakeholders.
So wanted to ask you,
Matt, how that's played out
in your organization.
How do you prioritize?
How do you share
responsibilities
across your team?
What's your org chart?
Do you have product managers?
How do they interact
with your developers?
Just trying to get a
sense of how it works.
How do you run your
shop, basically?
Yeah.
So Business Science
is a small company.
We are up to seven or eight now.
But mainly, compared to probably
Peloton, which has a lot
more than eight people--
so in my shop, I
wear a lot of hats.
My wife-- she's working, doing--
working with like businesses,
actual companies-- also working
with customer
service and finance.
So we have everyone at
Business Science-- we all
wear a lot of different hats.
We do have some role players.
We've got people
that are marketing.
I have consultants that
I've actually hired out too
that are helping me
with different products
that we're getting
ready to launch
or have launched already.
We now have a sales team.
But that's kind of
the extent of it.
As I'm growing in
this capacity--
and this is really new to
me, because a year ago,
we were three
people at this time.
It was me, my wife,
and then I just
had hired my first
official marketing guy.
His name's Mike.
So Mike joined the team, and
then fast forward a year later,
and now we're at seven.
So we're starting to grow
a little bit faster now.
But what I've seen
is, for me personally,
the challenges
are way different,
because being a course creator,
it's more technical in nature.
I'm thinking about, what
does a student need to learn?
How do I package this
into a product that's
going to effectively walk them
through all the major things,
but still be business-forward
and get them the early win
and can take them through
a whole business project?
But now, while I'm
still creating courses,
actually, some of
that has slowed down,
and now what I'm emphasizing
more in my role is leadership.
So leadership is something
that anybody can learn.
It's definitely a
learnable skill,
and it starts with caring.
This is the funny thing.
I've started to actually
call people up and just
let them know that
I care about them,
and talk with them
on a personal level
like, hey, where are you
trying to go in your life?
What are you trying to do,
and how can Business Science
best help you get there?
And I think that's something
that's maybe a little weird--
it could be a little
weird at first,
but it's something unique
that I do that has really
helped me identify with
people and really get
to understand them more.
And when I show them, OK,
this is how Business Science
can help you grow if you're
trying to become a better data
scientist, and also
working for my company.
How does that relate to what
you're doing at Peloton?
We can all get
better at leadership.
And I think that that's
really-- when you're working--
even if you're as a
project manager, where
you aren't necessarily
overseeing people,
but you do effectively have to
get them to do things in order
to help you do the project--
so just having that level
of leading by example
and getting to know the
person, showing them
how your project is going
to help them do better
with whatever their
goals are and how
it's going to help them
make things easier--
make it easier for them
or increase their status
in the company--
simple things.
People think people
are motivated by money
all the time.
That's a load of bull.
What people are really motivated
by, honestly, is things--
simple things, like recognition.
If they're going to
be part of the team
and this thing's a success,
I'm going to recognize you.
And I want you to know
that going into this.
You're going to be up
there with the whole team,
and we're going to
showcase everything that
went into this project, and--
simple things like that, that
can actually-- especially
if you're a project
manager, can really help.
So I don't know if
that makes sense.
I don't know if that's
helpful or not, but that's
my two cents at least.
Yeah, definitely,
all those things
ring true and relevant
to my situation here.
So thank you so much.
MATT DANCHO: You got it.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Thank you, Matt.
Juan, I see you asked
a great question
in the chat a bit earlier.
If you're still on, would you
want to jump in and ask that?
And I can-- oh, I
think you're unmuted.
There you are.
Hi.
Well, now, I was wondering, how
do you get over the imposter
syndrome?
I've been working with
data since sociologists
20 years ago, but with R
full-time since 2015, '16.
But I don't consider myself
a data scientist or a data
analyst, even though
I'm a sociologist
with political science.
I work with electoral data,
public opinion data, Twitter
data, but I don't know how
to get that step to consider
myself a data scientist.
Thank you, Matt.
Yeah.
This is a great one.
So I would venture to
say you're not alone.
Just a show of hands--
anybody else experience
imposter syndrome
at any point in your career?
Just put a six in the chat.
Put a six.
We'll do a six.
All right.
All right, so Juan, you're
seeing the chat, right?
Yes.
Lots of people are having
imposter syndrome too,
so that's the first thing.
I would say probably
90% of data scientists
experience some level
of imposter syndrome.
It's very common.
I experienced it.
I'll share with you my
story and some of the things
that I did to get over it.
But my problem was--
so I'm a data
scientist, self-trained.
I never went to school
for data science.
I was a mechanical engineer.
I worked in the
valve industry mainly
doing actually design work
and maintenance efforts,
and then managing a actual
team of engineers that did--
that built valves, basically.
I eventually got
into the sales group,
because they liked what
I was doing managerially
with that engineering group.
So I got some additional
responsibility,
and I started to work my
way up in the organization.
But I started learning data
science, and it wasn't easy.
It was far from it.
Honestly, it took me probably
at least four or five years
to think of myself as an
actual data scientist.
And there were some days
when I was going through it.
And I remember trying
to make reports,
and just nothing's
coming together.
I'm drawing blanks.
I'm just staring at the screen.
The cursor's blinking at me.
And I'm just like,
Matt, pull it together.
What the heck's wrong?
So people go through that--
and I venture to say at least 9
out of 10 data scientists.
It's pretty common.
So things that can help,
things that help me--
don't give up.
Every day is a new day, so try
and write at least one line
of code a day.
That was something
that I implemented
in my own personal journey,
and I did that for--
I don't know-- seven or
eight years straight.
And that single
activity of saying, hey,
I got to pull up
RStudio, I got to start--
I just got to put one
line of code in there.
And you know what's
going to happen?
It's a mental thing,
because you're
going to write more
than one line of code.
Who's going to stop at
one line of code, right?
I mean, it takes you--
so anyways, I
started doing that.
I started being
consistent with my habits.
I started really doubling
down on some of the things
that I was learning ggplot,
just getting visualizations.
Those are quick wins.
Once I learned
ggplot, I could then
start telling stories
to my management team.
And that was something that
nobody else in my company
was doing.
So I started focusing
on things like that
that weren't necessarily
overly complex,
like machine learning
or anything like that.
I set some of that stuff
aside and really focused
on the foundational things.
I got really good
with data wrangling.
That was another area where--
people in my company had
tough times when there was--
especially in a
SQL database, where
you've got a jillion tables.
Which ones do you pull in?
So I learned one table,
the customer table.
I learned the
transactions table.
I learned how to connect the
two and start to blend the data.
And this is stuff that people
had a really tough time
with in my company,
and it was something
that differentiated me.
And again, just a quick win--
you start to learn a
handful of dplyr functions,
like group_by and summarize.
How often is that
exactly the one-two punch
that your boss needs in order
to be able to gain insights?
So I really focused
on some of those.
One of my biggest mistakes
is I would get on LinkedIn,
and honestly, I
would see everyone
talking about deep learning.
This was back--
2016.
They would be talking
about TensorFlow, Keras.
That for me was a
huge black hole.
I got very limited
value out of that stuff.
True story-- I built a
regression model for my company
that ended up--
honestly, no joke-- helping me
take the part of the company
that I was overseeing from
about 3 million to 15 million
in revenue.
And it was a small
part of the company,
because the company made about
$500 million a year in revenue.
So this was kind of
a drop in the bucket.
But my boss all that, and
my boss's boss saw that,
and they were like, oh,
wow, this is really pretty
impressive what you're doing.
I implemented a lead scoring
algorithm that literally
was just a logistic regression.
Now, true story-- then I was
getting good results with that,
so I was like, oh, this
deep learning stuff--
this is pretty cool, right?
I was seeing what people
were doing online with it.
And they were like, oh, my gosh,
I can do image classification.
I can do this and that.
So I hauled off, and
I was like, all right,
I'm going to learn deep
learning, at least the basics,
and I'm going to try to apply
it to this lead scoring problem.
And I spent probably
six months on that,
and I got nothing out of it.
My logistic regression
model was better.
Just trying to
understand TensorFlow,
and then realizing
TensorFlow's too complicated,
so then I'm going
to switch to Keras.
And then, oh, somebody's
talking about PyTorch.
Actually, I can't
even if remember
PyTorch was out back then.
But it's just the process
of seeing all of these--
I call them red herrings.
They're these shiny objects out
there that are trying to steal
your attention, and it's taking
you away from the thing that
you're--
that's actually
giving you the value.
So data wrangling, ggplot--
work on those.
Get the foundations.
Get the basics done,
and get the quick wins,
and then work your
way up as you go.
Then machine learning ended
up being really powerful
for me, and some other stuff.
So I hope that helps.
Thank you, Matt, for
doing the numbers thing too,
because I think it's
always helpful to just see
how many other people
are feeling that as well.
Yep, yep.
Imposter syndrome's a big one.
Even my students,
a lot of them--
that can be, honestly,
the sole reason that they
jump into my program, is because
whatever they're taking, they--
it's just not
getting them through.
They always feel every--
for two steps forward, they're
taking one step backwards.
So you hate to see that.
And that's something
I'm on a mission
to help my students at
least get through that.
Definitely.
Siavash, I see you had
your hand raised too.
I know Siavash.
How's it going, man?
Hi, Matt.
I'm a student,
and proud student.
I'm really enjoying
the time series course.
MATT DANCHO: Great.
SIAVASH SOLEYMANI: I really
thought that it was a--
I'm already doing a
lot of time series,
so it's going to
be a quick course.
But it's a lot of
functions that I struggled
and I spent a lot of
time to just write them.
Some of these helper functions
make my life much easier.
And I'm still not throughout the
course, so I appreciate that.
My question is, what is the next
big thing in Business Science?
I'm very looking forward--
what you're working on
and when it will be coming.
So I'm working on two
big things right now.
The first one is actually a
program that combines-- so
for those of you who don't
know how Business Science is
structured, I have a
core product, which
is called the 5 Course R-Track.
The time series
course that is taking
is the third course
in that system.
And it's basically
designed to take you
from wherever you are now to
being super productive, being
able to outcompete all
of your competition
if you're trying to get a job,
or if you already have a job
and you're trying to
apply data science,
give you all the
skills necessary--
things like Shiny, things
like the data wrangling,
the visualization.
Time series, which
was a huge win for me
when I was working back in
the day for Bonney Forge,
but the next big thing
is to take that system
and add on an
additional course to it.
But also, the
additional course is
to help get you a data
science job in 30 days.
And then the whole
package is designed
to also add in a
personalized coach
that takes you through
the entire program
in under 180 days, along
with a whole group that goes
through the process with you.
So one of the big hurdles
that I was finding
is that some people--
like Siavash, you're
highly self-motivated
and you're crushing the courses.
But these courses-- I
mean, they're pretty dense,
because they go deep into how
to solve the business problems
and get--
and that's where you
get the value out of it.
But it's very easy for
life or a curveball
to come, and to get sidetracked
and then stay unmotivated.
So we want to have a coach that
helps take you through that
whole process, somebody who's--
and it's designed for people
who want to get data
science positions.
So that way, whether they want
to get a senior data science
position through
the beta program--
I've already had one student
get a job at Air Canada.
She got it in four months
using this program.
Another student,
she's 22 years old.
Her name is [? Habi. ?]
I actually hired her
on as my next coach because
she is so fantastically
good at getting a data
science interview,
it's disgustingly scary.
But she has all the
tricks in the book,
and she knows how to take
that, the curriculum--
you guys have to hear this.
She had no prior data
science experience,
working as a data scientist.
She had no prior
working experience other
than she used to sell wine
for her dad's business.
Her dad owned a company
that distributed wine.
So she was able to, in seven
months with this program,
be able to get her
first data science job--
she just landed it here
about two weeks ago--
at the Federal Reserve in
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
So she crushed it.
And I had to hire her on
because she had everything
stacked against her--
no working experience
prior to that.
So that's the first thing
that I'm working on.
We're getting ready
to productionalize
that because I have to have a
sales team to help sell that.
It's a higher ticket product
because of the coaching aspect,
but the results that
it gets are amazing.
So to productionalize that just
takes a little bit more work.
So we're probably going to be
launching that here in January.
And then the other thing
that I have in beta right now
is I'm leveraging--
I always seek my
past for guidance,
and one of the things
I'm doing right now
is with consulting,
teaching people who have--
who are dangerous with R
to learn how to turn that
into a business, whether
it's a side hustle
or actually creating a
scalable business model.
I'm teaching them how to do
things like find their niche,
how to develop an
offer that there's
market demand for
already out there, how
to create a business, and how
to basically do everything
from take--
to generate leads to building
out a sales presentation
and selling clients.
And the goal is to land $25,000
plus data science projects,
and then to be able to
scale that, so that way
what they do--
their first client pays
them to build it, and then
their next client
they shrink the time,
because they've already got most
of the code written already,
and they can reproduce it.
And it becomes a
scalable business model.
So that's the next project
I'm working on right now.
I have nine students
in that beta program.
And we're just through the
first week of it right now,
but it's going
really well so far.
So cross my fingers--
I'm hoping to launch that
probably mid-next year.
SIAVASH SOLEYMANI: Awesome.
Thank you very much.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Matt, I know you
have a hard stop at
the top of the hour
with kids running
in on vacation, too,
so I want to make sure to
get to a few other questions.
But I know, Frank, asked one
in the chat a bit earlier.
I was trying to
scroll up and find it.
You want to ask live here?
FRANK: I can go quick.
So Matt, thinking about
your classes, putting--
remembering back to
when I was taking them,
and then you were talking
about the webinars and some
of the techniques
that you learned
and you used to keep
people on the call
through the whole webinar,
it made me wonder about some
of the analytics behind
people taking the courses
and if there's anything
that you learned there
about how data people
either like to learn,
or how they learn, and
how you use that to change
how you create courses.
One of the things
that pops to mind
is, what is the
data science topic
that we 2x playback
speed through the most
frequently, anything like that?
Yeah.
So I find learners are either
2x learners, 1.5x learners,
or 1x learners.
Once they get the
hang of how to do 2x,
it's like you're never
going to go back, right?
I do at least 1 and 1/2x on
all of my YouTube videos.
That's how I crush through a
lot of content a lot of times.
And I find that a lot of
learners, when it comes
to analyzing how they learn--
so one of the biggest metrics
that I started out with
was understanding if
my courses were better
than the rest of the market.
So I pride myself on as--
just as an online format,
it is insanely tough to even
get people to take your course.
So couple of things
we do differently--
I think the Slack
channel with the support,
getting the support--
as soon as they have a problem,
they can hop in there, get an--
ask any question-- no
question's off the table--
and really get feedback
at the speed of learning.
I think that's
incredibly important.
When I implemented that, really
helped take my completion rates
up.
Now, the other thing--
so having a community
like that really helps.
Keeping videos small--
I think that's super critical.
So there's this thing.
I can't remember the
name of the curve,
but people learn in a--
it's a U-shaped curve.
So if you do an hour
webinar, people only
remember the first part
of it and the end of it.
In the middle,
they're only going
to-- their chances
of remembering
that-- it's like 3% to 5%.
But at the beginning
and end-- so
if you can shrink that time
down-- and one of the things
I did was I try to keep no
video longer than five minutes.
So you're going to at least
remember the beginning and end
of each of those videos.
And then it's also
going to be M&amp;Ms.
They're just going to
pop one after the other,
rather than having to eat
a whole big pile at once.
So those are some
of the things that I
started implementing
that really I saw
move the needle for my program.
A lot of other stuff
that we do differently,
starting off with a
business problem first,
I think that's super critical.
Getting them a quick win,
showing them a jumpstart--
not a full analysis, but a
bite-size analysis so they
can begin with the end in mind.
They can see and visualize
how this course is
going to play out and how
that value is going to stack.
And then by the
end of it, they're
beyond thrilled because they
saw just at the beginning what
they're going to accomplish.
That's funny
about the jumpstart.
I felt like I had
learned the whole class
after the jumpstart.
I got my value.
And then it's just
putting in the pieces
and going just a
little bit deeper
with some of the concepts.
Yeah.
So once you get
through the jumpstart,
you already-- you know
where you're going.
It's just, how do I get there?
A lot of it's muscle
memory, repetition
with some of those
functions, and just
really understanding
how people learn.
In terms of data
science, I don't
do a whole lot of data science
on-- analytics on actually
the learning journey.
I do more analytics now-- one
of the big things that really
helped me was understanding,
as my email list has grown,
that everybody is not
necessarily one size fits all,
hit them with R track.
A portion of them
are going to buy in.
And yes, certainly, that's true.
But we're starting now to get
segments that are very new,
and maybe they just
need a beginner.
Or maybe they want
a book at first
to warm them up to
me, rather than--
and certainly, some people are
ready to jump into the R track.
And that's what I normally sell.
Especially if they
are on our webinar,
I'm going to present
that offer to them
because, normally, if they're
investing an hour plus time,
they're pretty
committed at that point.
But some people,
especially if they're just
teetering on the edge
of, what is data science,
is it right for me, that's
a different product.
That's a book.
So we got to start to
understand our customers,
where they're at in their
own learning journey,
and present the right
offer at the right time
in order to be able to help
them through that process.
FRANK: That was awesome.
Thank you.
MATT DANCHO: Yep.
Thank you so much, Matt,
for joining us today.
I know we're getting right
to the top of the hour,
and you have to run.
But there's a few questions
that went unanswered.
Is it OK if I send those over
to you maybe on LinkedIn and--
MATT DANCHO: Yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: OK.
So full disclosure,
guys, I'm down here
with my family in
Key West, Florida.
We got a flight at
5 o'clock, so I'm
trying to enjoy the last
little bit of pool time
I'm going to have with my kids.
But yeah, definitely, Rachael,
send me those questions over.
We'll get them answered.
I'll do that promptly.
Hopefully, by tomorrow
or the weekend,
I'll get them back to you and
then you can shoot them out.
Wait till next week.
You go run to the
pool time right now.
Don't worry about
MATT DANCHO: All right.
--the other questions.
[CHUCKLES] Thank you so
much, Matt, for joining us
and for all the great
[? questions. ?]
Yeah.
It was so great
being on here, guys.
Honestly, Rachael, it's an honor
for you to invite me on here.
And whatever you
guys are doing, just
know that you're
on the right path
here with R, with data science.
It's really going to help you.
It helped my career.
I know it's going to
help you guys too.